[Music]
hi everyone so today I be discussing the
topic of active learning and the concept
of like why active learning is important
for data and notation and getting like
awesome training data sets so I start by
introducing myself real quickly so so as
I will said I am the vp of machine
learning at a company called figure 8
figure 8 used to be a used to be called
CrowdFlower so more people know us by
CrowdFlower so we're basically the
enterprise version of Amazon Mechanical
Turk so large companies and and AI
startups would basically come to us to
get training data because usually when
you collect data you don't have labels
with them and so with with those data
and so you have to you know you have to
get those labels somewhere so prior to
joining figure 8 I was and I was
actually working for Atlassian as their
chief data scientist Atlassian if you
don't know is the company that makes a
JIRA
bitbucket confluence and so far since so
on and prior to that I was actually
working for Walmart labs basically
hiding their data science research for
the search team and so a lot of the work
I've done was related to like getting
good training data and I accidentally
became in charge of the person in charge
of this and this is how I learned about
how important it is to have high quality
training data and how difficult it is to
get good labels I'm also part of the
expert network at a company called IAEA
the International Institute for
analytics and so I basically like
consult with lots of different types of
companies about different topics
including the Thai labeling and so one
of the the advantages I have is I have
seen lots of different types of data and
I know a little bit about all the
different use cases that you can see out
there so let's go back to a figure-eight
specifically so our mission is as I said
I provide like health AI companies AI
teams across the world like get high
quality training data so that they can
train
so machine learning models and so so
I'll show you like what is difficult
about getting training data today and so
this is our agenda agenda for this talk
so I'll start by talking about big data
and how big data is important for
machine learning and then we will talk
about the challenge of detailing and
then I will give you like an active
learning tutorial and some tips about
how to get started with with active
learning
alright so why I mean I think everybody
knows that we live in an era of big data
right and big data is everywhere and
sometimes people may ask this question
like how come how come this is happening
right now right and so also why why is
why is it that it makes data scientists
and machine learning specialists so so
happy right and so this is what we're
talking about today so we all know that
the amount of data available worldwide
is growing really quickly one of the
metrics I like to state is typically
like over the course of 18 months to 24
months we basically double the amount of
data we have we collect as you can see
here right I mean so it's really growing
extremely fast and so basically if you
you think on those terms it means that
every 18 to 24 months we basically
generate as much data as the rest of
humankind before us which is completely
crazy you probably also saw like this in
like what happens in an internet minute
like lots of things happening because
now we have social media we have IOT and
so there is just like a lot of data
being generated just because we're very
active online so I mean you can also ask
this question like how come this is
happening now and it almost seems like
we have suddenly become interesting as a
species but that's that's just not the
case so why is it when we see so much
data today because number one there is a
surge in new data data formats ten years
ago most of the data we were collecting
was text today you see lots of different
lots of different types of data like
lidar data which is like basically the
type of data you collect when
if you have a self-driving car video
lots and lots of images pictures we take
and audio and so forth and so on so the
landscape of the type of data were
working with today as as data scientist
has changed it's also because we have
new technologies right so what I mean
when I talk about new technologies it's
for different reasons that this is
helping us collect more data number one
we have better storage we have more
storage we have cloud technologies it's
easier and easier to transfer data
quickly from point A to point B then we
also have social media social media is
empowering us to deliver in January data
share data with the rest of the world on
on a day to day basis and at every
moment of our lives
similarly IOT is also helping us like
generate data at the personal level when
you think about like your phone is now
capable of recording pretty much
everything you do same thing for your
feed bit it's just an opportunity that's
been created to generate data at a
person level when a couple of years back
was more of an enterprise level but then
there is another reason why data is
growing so quickly and this is because
of data duplication and so this is kind
of important for the rest of the talk so
I'm gonna spend some time here when you
do a search on Google you can do
searches for like lots of technical
topics you will always get the same type
of results I searched for my plot lib
installation and I get all these
different results but if you actually
click on each one of them you're gonna
get pretty much the same page with like
exceptions around versioning or really
minor changes so at the end of the day
all of these pages are the same
information you'll see the same problem
when people retweet things share things
over and over again on on social media
so more data does not necessarily equate
more information and that's that's been
a problem for the eita scientists today
like big data which was originally an
opportunity is also becoming an a
liability because you have more more
data to process so now that we've talked
about Big Data I would like to to
basically share my views on like why I
really think that proper labeling is
important right so computer vision is a
really hot
these days but it's actually something
that's been around for a while now so
and so the theory about that that
surrounds like a computer vision and
deep learning has been around for a
while like deep learning or neural
networks the the concept that goes into
deep learning has been invented in the
40s and going to like computer vision
like there was like basically that was a
project started in academia in the late
60s to basically like people believe
that over the course of one summer we
would be in a position to have computers
understand images better than humans and
as we know like it's been a while that
we're trying to solve that problem and
it did not happen in the 60s because
it's really a problem that's much much
bigger than than we thought it would be
but as we all know like there's been
recent progress on computer vision very
recently and actually started to see
huge progress like ever since the
beginning of the - that 2010 and so we
have this like a challenge I think
everybody knows here in image net right
I mean so there is like this data said
that people used to basically like a try
to improve on the previous version and
so as of like 2015 we are now have
models that understand images better
than humans
so we epic surpassed the the basically
like a it's like a superhuman computer
capability computer vision right so how
come this has happened so recently and
so my my guess for this is that this
happened ever since there's been the
famous label label data set called image
net image net is a dataset of like 14
million images of which are labeled
across like 20,000 different categories
right and so you just publish this this
data set and all of the sudden you have
like this pair of new ideas and improve
models on in computer vision so this
basically tells me that if you have high
quality training data you can actually
do a lot of things with it and this is
why we could never do anything before
because getting 14 million labelled
images is just something you cannot do
on your own
alright so now that I hope everybody's
can
instead getting big data and label big
data is a key to advanced machine
learning research let's talk about like
the concept of labeling what happens
when you're labeling so we were facing a
huge problem I will say that where our
our problem as data scientists a few
years ago was to collect data
now it's shifted to label data I call
that the big data labeling crisis
basically if you think about this huge
amount of data was just reach the point
recently where even if every single
human on the planet would just like do
nothing else but labeling we wouldn't
have enough manpower to take care of
everything and so it's a problem because
you have all of this data available to
you but you cannot do anything with it
unless it's labeled properly so you have
two ways to address the problem either
you label faster using a machine
learning algorithm on your label smarter
and we'll talk about that in a minute
but I'll start by explaining what
labeling faster means so this is an
example of a tool that we have developed
that figure-eight recently so and it's
basically our video annotation tool
video has been a problem because if you
want like if I'm a self-driving car
company Tesla uber like way mo you need
to label I'll put bounding boxes so
basically put rectangles around the
people are different types of ontology
zon an image before you can train a
model right and so this data has to be
extremely high quality because if you
miss a pedestrian in your in your your
image you can basically like that maybe
make the difference between life and
death when when you actually deploy a
self-driving our software in in so first
self-driving car so basically the
problem we have is like typical videos
have like 30 frames per second and so if
you have like a suburban scene like this
like you can have like 20 30 different
like cars per per image so for 10
seconds of video that multiplied by 30
multiplied by 20 that would already take
like about one hour and 40 minutes for a
person to label this manually and that's
that's assuming that we take one second
per box which is like really and her
unrealistic like in real life that will
probably take
around like three three to four hours so
this is just not possible right because
this is ten seconds and like if I'm Way
more I don't need 10 seconds I need like
ten thousand ten thousand hours of
videos to be annotated properly with
different ontology etcetera etc so what
we've done is like we created a tool
where you annotate the first frame and
then the algorithm basically tracks the
objects across the different frames and
you just ask humans to validate what
they see and it's much much faster it's
actually like increasing the speed of
annotation by a factor of 100 and so
this is this is one example of the
things we do but we do that later at 4
NLP we do that for images we put
predictive bounding boxes on images
automated segmentation and so forth and
so on but just shows you that we've
reached the point where you need to use
machine learning to provide the training
data for other people to do machine
learning so it's a it's a pretty cool
area to be in
so this is the like typically you would
use like object detectors that exist on
the market so like you'll OSS DRC and
then like these are all like a
open-source version of algorithm that
help you identify objects on on an image
and so basically you know that the
accuracy is never gonna be 100% so when
you have a problematic box like this one
over there you would basically I have a
human fix it and put in the right place
so that he enriched like a really really
high accuracy so this is how you label
faster is it good enough in my opinion
it's not good enough and there are
actually other things that you can do
alright so there are other problems like
related to data labelling that are not
just associated with volume it's also
associated with the difficulty to get
the right labels right and so when we
talk about labeling what I just showed
is like putting a box around the car on
an image this is something that anyone
can do quickly right there are other
cases where it's difficult to obtain
because the label is something that a
doctor needs to write or someone who
specialized it's also something that can
be really hard to label in some cases
labeling means that you need to run
blood tests on the patient and you're
gonna have to wait for some time to get
results back for for that specific
person it can be super expensive like if
I want to label like a position enough
oil in in the ground to basically
validate like my prediction for Lika
where I should put my my oil wins then
it may be like solver solvents or like
hundreds of thousands of dollars just to
identify the basically put a label on
your on your data it can be extremely
time-consuming so even simple things
like identifying a topic for a document
may require you to read the entire
document and so if it's like a long like
a 10 page document then even a simple
label is something that can take like a
couple of hours or like even a couple of
minutes that will be already a lot of
time to improve on it can even be
dangerous sometimes like if you're just
like trying to identify if there is a
landmine as you predicted and
specifically realloc labeling it would
basically mean that somebody has to risk
their lives
alright so so now I'd like to talk about
semi-supervised learning and so this is
something that I guess everybody heard
of but doesn't not necessarily think
about when they're building models so
we're all used in using super supervised
learning supervised learning is like 90%
of the machine learning world today most
of the deep learning applications we
have today are based on a supervised
approach so supervised learning is when
you have label data and so in this case
if I want a binary classifier between
trucks and cars I'm gonna have to have
something someone are like a person or a
machine that you call an Oracle
basically provide those labels for you
you can also rely on unsupervised
learning unsupervised learning is
powerful because it doesn't require
labels but you will just be able to
cluster or like recreate different
categories for these different objects
or whether you see that all the trucks
are in the blue circles was identified
properly but you still don't know that
these type of object is called is called
a truck right and so this is the witness
of a unsupervised
there is a sweet spot in the middle that
we don't leverage enough in my opinion
so it's called so many supervised
learning and so it's basically this
approach that consists in taking the
levers you have and
the unlabeled data that you have at the
same time and try to get the best of
both worlds and try to combine both so
basically the approach we've had we've
taken so far is like we when we have a
training set we want to label everything
and we use that to train our models but
you can actually like be smart about how
much you label and when you label your
data so you can decide to select
basically the data that you think is the
most valuable for your model prior to
building a model that would be called
something called prioritization you just
try to identify which which one of your
data points are spam which one dies
which ones are hurtful for your model
which ones I use less for your model
which ones out duplicates right I mean
because like not like saying that you
don't want to use a data point in your
training set doesn't necessarily mean
that this data is bad maybe some some
piece of information you already have
you can decide to make that choice of
put like choosing to use or not use a
specific data rows and query your label
for it while you're training the model
this is what active learning does and
then finally you can also decide to like
build a model using less data and then
use a human-like
override position basically to do that
so I can build a model that I know is
not going to be accurate but I'm gonna
you I'm gonna use like a human in the
loop approach to basically take care of
the cases where my model failed or like
validate so it's pretty much the same
option that we talked about before right
ok so I actually think that active
learning is actually more powerful than
just like a labeling like if you think
about activity for learning different
here will actually show you this so this
is the way we as data scientists used to
think about the way we do our work we
would first build a data set right and
so I actually even called that
data science PTSD 10 years ago when it
was hard to get data which is like focus
or like I need to gather data even if I
don't know what I'm gonna do with it and
so basically you would not have the
opportunity to get the right training
set not necessarily the right features
not necessary to
qty not necessarily the best practices
that you need to put around creating a
dataset and then later you would take
this data and build a model for it so
basically you would be forced to adapt
the model to the data and not the other
way around because we have big data
today and we can get picky about the
data we use and because gathering
collecting data is becoming easier and
easier you can actually simul tenuously
build a model and your dataset that ADA
said that goes with it and this is what
really what active learning actually
offers you alright so let's let in like
let me show you exactly how this works
so active learning basically is a it's
basically a process where you
incrementally add more and more data and
queue into your your model as you train
it so you start with unlabeled and
unlabeled training set and then you will
select some rows within this unlabeled
training set that you will label and
then depending on your results you will
add more and more and more and so this
approach is called like pulling active
learning so let me show you a little
I'll show you that and then I'll show
you a quick demo of how this works
so basically active learning is about
getting better learning curves what you
see the graph you see over there is
basically like showing like the the
y-axis shows the accuracy or the quality
of a model and the x-axis shows the
amount of label data and so what you see
in gray is what you would have if you
were to throw more data randomly like
like as an incremental supervised
learning so you're incrementally adding
more and more data but there is no
intelligence in the way that you decide
to add data right I mean so each one of
those samples that you add incrementally
are going to be random randomly selected
of course it goes up because we all know
that the more data the more there are
higher you get the accuracy is active
learning is about like allowing the
model to learn faster so now if you have
the option of deciding what data you
want to put into the system and you know
which one is going to be the most
beneficial for your model then you can
you can have the model
learn faster and reach higher accuracy
even faster right and so in this case
here if you like you see the little dots
over there so you can reach 80% accuracy
with that specific model using like a
forty five percent of the the total size
of the data set of the training set
versus like seventy percent if you were
not to use active Ronnie there are cases
where it's much more than that I've seen
cases when you actually like you'd only
need like ten percent of the data to
reach the same accuracy so this is
basically the way it works for polling
so this is like a skiers I think I'm
gonna get here you have a large pool of
unlabeled data it's available to Lou you
you've collected it and so then you have
to select an initial sample the problem
with the initial sample is you don't
know anything about the data because
this data is not labeled and you've not
done anything with it so it's like an
explorer exploit problem you have to
guesstimate at first which one of your
data set which one of the data points
within your data set are gonna be the
most beneficial and then you take this
small sample and you send that a human
Oracle can actually be a machine anymore
called that and that's going to provide
your labels for this now you you have a
label the initial sample right and you
will basically use this data to train
the model that you have
of course because you didn't use a lot
of data you don't expect to have a very
high accuracy but probably higher than
if you had like randomly selected your
your training set at first and so now
you have a small label training set you
have a trained model not not with a
really high accuracy but it's available
to you so guess what you're gonna use
this this this data this this model now
and you're going to use this model to
infer the labels on the remaining of the
data right and so so basically these are
synthetics labels at this point now the
cool thing is like since you run an
inference you're gonna have metadata on
on basically the entire data right there
and so you'll have things like entropy
like confidence levels you'll get like
margin between like the first best
prediction and second best prediction
and so forth and so on and so all this
metadata that you generated the helps
you identify what is the best the most
useful the most useful strategy to pick
your next sample and then once you've
done that you actually throw that so
that this human annotator can give you
real labels it's a very powerful
technique because you're not actually
using synthetic labels at no point in
time like others so me supervised
learning approaches are dangerous
because you use synthetic labeled data
right and so in this case you just use
synthetic labels to identify what data
you should label but at the end of the
day you're using real labels provided by
humans or are like a good machine
running model to basically tell you what
these images were in the specific case
and then you start over so you have more
data and you and you add the CETA into
your model you're still gonna use the
data you had in the first place and now
you you hope that your accuracy is gonna
go higher and higher and higher and so
eventually you stop when you decide that
your accuracy is high enough or you run
out of budget if you had a specific
budget for labeling or if you ran out of
time and so forth and so on so there are
different like reasons how you would
stop so how like intuitively how does
this work so this works because like in
this specific case here it I mean so I
have lots of data points of a verified
run a linear regression model over this
I would get the line that you see on the
picture if I have like I had this extra
few points over there you can see like
the type of difference you would have
here right so if you were to randomly
pick like and sample out of all these
points all the blue points dark brown
points and and the light points you
would basically have these are like a
well I mean if I randomly pick things I
would get more points in the blue part
to the point that maybe I only get blue
points like
light blue points instead of getting so
basically I would get this dotted line
instead of having the hard line over
there and so basically it tells you that
you have to be intelligent in the way
that you do your random sampling and you
have to understand from here that the
dark blue points actually more valuable
because they are more restrictive they
are giving you more restriction on your
model and so it helps you learn faster
all right so basically what you have to
remember here is like not all rules are
equally are created equal all right so
now let's like go like really quickly in
different strategies so what you saw is
like called pooling you have another
type of strategy called streaming
streaming is basically UI you decide not
to use or not to use a specific data
point basis based on the threshold that
you put over there you can say like I'm
gonna reuse whatever data that for which
I did not have 80% accuracy I had less
than 80 percent accuracy and and decide
to use that to retrain your model as you
go problem with that you cannot really
constraint your problem right yeah I
mean so B so basically like if you're
unlucky and all the data that you
inferred was less than 80% accuracy then
you're gonna use all of your data and
your basic you cannot have a supervised
learning approach pooling is basically
what we saw before so it's it's really
great for our business case because
people are trying to minimize their
budget and so this helps you keep your
budget under control so how do you pick
data smartly at every single active
running pool
there are lots of different ways to do
this and so one of them would be like
something called uncertainty and
certainty would be based on confidence
level knowledge from confidence level
from margin sampling from the entropy of
the of the data and so forth and so on
the other would be like query by a
committee chronic by committees
basically you use several models like an
ensemble method and you try to see in
which cases the models disagree if they
disagree you would actually consider
that this data point in particular is
difficult to learn and so
therefore you would add that to your
training set label it and move forward
and then you have much more
sophisticated kind of strategies based
on like expected model change so this is
even cooler because like you would
basically try pick a specific data point
and try to predict if the level of
information you would gain would
actually be beneficial for your model
and so basically like in that at that
point in time you would be doing
something that's more of the order of
like a Monte Carlo simulations and so
forth and so on so you basically try to
identify which data points in your
training set would be the most
beneficial for your model so why is this
so complicated right um so we've seen
that you have like pulling and streaming
you also have something else called
synthetic query generation which I will
not dig into picking the querying
strategy is really hard in fact there is
no framework for it and this is one of
the things that we started working on it
figure eight because people try and see
if it works like usually the way the way
you go by this is just identify like
this seems a reasonable querying
strategy for instance I'm gonna take the
100 lowest confidence levels among the
infra datato as a query strategy in my
active learning loops but you cannot
know in advance if it's gonna work and
you're not gonna know if it's the best
one for you pulling size how much more
data you want to add at every single
loop and how many loops do you want to
use before you stop and so for all of
this there is no framework on the market
and there is literally no research on
that topic people like whoever is doing
actually even in academia is doing reach
like they are doing research based on
guesstimates I believe the squaring
strategy is going to work I will try it
if it doesn't work if it works it
doesn't work this is what I report in my
paper all right so really quickly so
misconceptions are about like active
running in general right so I will say
that active running is not a type of
model it's actually a wrapper or
strategy around the model so it means
that you can do deep active learning you
can leverage active learning regardless
of the type of model you're using so you
don't have to change your model you can
actually go ahead use the model you have
and go and improve on it
other misconception would be like it's a
mathematical formula it does not need to
be a Mexican mathematical formula and
the querying strategy is actually a
sampling strategy that you used to like
identify what the best next pool of data
is going to be for you and it can
actually be something that's
non-deterministic it can be a specific
way to to to to sample that's not random
sampling right all right so why do you
want to like I will give you an examples
of something that happens on the market
typically people use like they look at
the confidence level of the data they
have inferred and they would use the
would the data with the lowest
confidence level and this is a bad
strategy because you might actually be
throwing spam into your system what
we've actually done at figure-eight is
we basically take medium confidence we
take among this medium confidence sample
some of them being the lowest within
that sample the highest confidence
within that sample and then some
randomly sample in the middle twin
ensure you you don't induce any biases
this would induce biases big time
because you're actually throwing data
that seems to like is potentially going
to be spamming and then the other
problem we've seen is like people
believe that at the end of the day you
want to reach the very maximum accuracy
you still need to use supervised
learning because the more data the
better however if you use active
learning because you're actually in the
business of identifying what data is
helpful or not helpful you are you doing
a better job with overfitting because
your ensuring diversity of your training
set you may also be able to remove spam
automatically and so in some cases you
actually get a higher accuracy even if
you go all the way using active learning
because you inject your data in a
different order
Nyko clear all right so what do what do
we want you to remember here so good
data is important for machine learning
specifically if it's labeled we do have
a problem with big data labelling crisis
this day so as we've seen you can label
starters so my suggestion is let's try
to label smarter about active learning
specifically so as you've seen like it
allows you to improve on your accuracy
it is an enhancement on your existing
model so you don't have to give up
whatever model you're working on you
just need to add this piece of
intelligence on top of it because it's a
strategy and not a model and
unfortunately it can be difficult
because there is no framework currently
to identify the right query strategy but
there is more research coming on that
topic thank you
[Music]